we are pleased to be joined right now by
all-time Buffalo Bills great Jim Kelly
before he goes in for lunch
and there's brisket just at the window
vacant spaces at you good to see you dr.
Ali good to see you it's better be seen
in view hahahahahaha I like that one Jim
and it's great to see you
you know how are you feeling how's it
going I'm no present I have my next MRI
with a couple weeks in New York City's
he'll be flying there but overall I'm
doing pretty good I can't complain okay
life's good kids good what's good oh my
yeah I get to tell this I almost tweeted
this because I told my wife it was that
good okay so a couple months ago my wife
says via text it says hello sweetie just
need to tell you a few things cool
number one I miss you my uncle number
two I love you I'm like wow number three
our daughter's wedding is going to cost
a mini fortune have a good day I have a
good day this good way to end and I'm
like oh no that means for me keep
working so you're planning a wedding
right now is oh yeah my daughter Erin
who is my oldest she's getting married
in January and the reason for January
wedding is her fiance is a baseball
player he's just tried to buy the middle
walk you Brewers and so just go through
all that in the summer and cool that
means early on with a coolant
destination where they may be to Hawaii
or Mexico or some really nice you know
tropical island and no we get married in
Buffalo okay I like after New York I
would say no no I trust me I love
Buffalo I still live there but I thought
wedding may be a little salty way to get
a little warmer sometimes you as they
all say pick your battles and this
year's one where I was going to win Jim
Kelly here and the Rich Eisen chill
again moments before the luncheon begins
here for kickoff essentially the big
stuff that goes down this weekend and I
heard you talk a little bit rich about
that room give only for hall of famers
getting to be honest with you I never
dreamt about the Hall of Fame where I'm
from no small town and I grew up watch
the Steelers you know Bradshaw and
Franco and all those guys Joe green and
Jack ham and Lambert and all those guys
and never in a million years I ever
would
think I'd be a part of it so when I was
picked to be a member of class of 2002
the red Nitschke lunch and I walked in
the first people I see Gale Sayers
Deacon Jones Merlin Olsen I mean I go
Rodgers style back and you know Bob
Griese all the guys that I admired and I
put on a pedestal I saw those guys and I
didn't feel that I deserve to be there I
mean I'm thinking what am I doing here
you know with all these legends and then
all of a sudden there's guys that you're
going in now they would call me mr.
Kelly yeah not like oh why am I really
not getting this but I'm just a blessed
man because we just had our photo taken
with all the Hall of Famers and of
course you're some people say own make
room for the Buffalo Bills well some
people might not like it but we will we
do our team photo as far as a whole
group of all the Hall of Famers the
Buffalo Bills are always together me
Bruce Thurmond Andre Marvell Polian
James Lofton we're all right there Joao
de la mole or Billy Shaw we always take
a picture together and we always in the
team photo we're always together because
we are proud to say that we all made it
we're proud to know that we have a
family that we all support each other
and we do things together and some
people look at that I'm not real happy
that all the Buffalo Bills always get
together because there's teams out there
that have Hall of Famers and they go do
their own thing that guy goes to
standardise way over there but all the
Buffalo Bills are always together and
I'm product who should be there who do
you think from the bills on your bills
teams um that is missing from that
photograph I think I think in due time
Steve Tasker won't get in because I
think they're realizing now that special
teams is that big part of footballing
if you really remember when you hear
head coaches a lot of times a stage
there's always three phases to a game
there's offense defense and special
teams well Steve Tasha was not always
double-teamed he's triple teamed a ton
and one other God move in brown he was I
think an eight nine time Pro Bowler
unbelievable player went from the
Buffalo Bills with the Chicago make it
per Bowl there so he's one guy talking
Abreu
it definitely deserves to be in it so
we'll say I want to take a break 60
seconds here with Jim Kelly come back
we'll talk about the current bills also
we'll ask you the poll question based on
what is going on in the AFC East with
the Miami Dolphins quarterback right now
with Ryan's hanging all going down but
maybe not so much going down it's an odd
situation with his knee where where
they're wondering if it should have
surgery take care of it now or try and
go into the season potentially Jim Kelly
is here on the Rich Eisen show
Al Michaels and Cris Collinsworth right
behind him Steve Largent as well we're
live from Canton Ohio that's what's
going on here on the Rich Eisen show on
a Hall of Fame Friday yes welcome back
indeed and the doors are opening -
welcome back dozens upon dozens upon
dozens of returning Hall of Famers
including Dan Marino and Bob Griese is
just walking by the door how cool is
this practice but I've never seen
anything seen Kelly sitting here Jim
it's so cool for us just to be looking
to our left and one hall-of-famer after
another strolls by I hear you're not in
and you're why did that I know I still
at times have to pinch myself because as
I looked and I've gotten to know Bob
Griese real well and of course growing
up a Steeler fan you know the Dolphins
against the Steelers and all that just
it's just amazing that they're for real
and they're a good guy they're not like
something that you can't talk to you up
and it's just like a normal conversation
just like you Jim just like you Jim
Kelly and the reason PEO is interesting
I plucked Marino's name up for reason
and then Bob Griese strolls but I want
to talk about the Dolphins quarterback
situation Ryan Tannehill
coach Adam GaSe about a half an hour ago
meeting with the media in South Florida
saying right now Matt as in Matt Moore
is our quarterback
we'll see where we go from there because
I've got to figure out what's going on
with Ryan and he said that everything is
on the table is an option including
surgery to repair the partially torn
left knee that he's seen the tweaked or
anger or whatever he did yesterday but
he didn't damage it apparently any
further and that's our poll question of
the day our TrueCar poll question if
you're looking to sell your car there's
an now a new better way to do it with
true car it's fast it's easy the best
way to price your car from the come
at home when you're ready we experience
a better way to sell or trade in your
car check out true car comm / trade
today Brockman read it out to the
listeners as well as Jim Kelly's didn't
rise yeah Ryan Tannehill can't go this
year guys who should be the Dolphins
quarterback this season Matt more Jay
Cutler Colin Kaepernick Tony Romo Wow
totally roll oh come on people get off
at night he's better than all three of
those guys yeah but still he he picked
another profession hello let it rest um
wow that Jay Cutler I don't know I mean
the guy that's been there with them now
the backup
that's um Matt Moore yeah give me an
opportunity he's young I mean it's not
that you know but he's young enough and
I'll stop there
I don't know it's just in terms of that
I mean you know Cutler is somebody who
he's known gays yeah from Chicago which
is why the reason why he's being brought
up right now when you when you retired
did you get any calls like he has very
loud I almost signed with the Baltimore
Ravens Ted marks brothers there and he
left Buffalo and he was my offensive
coordinator and I knew and when I was
going back to be honest with you that
was after my son was diagnosed with his
fatal disease and Hunter and I was going
to donate all the money to him and then
the more I talked to the wife and the
more that I really got involved in what
was going on all with my son I knew the
best thing for me to do and stay retired
and even though in my heart I always
wanted to be only a Buffalo Bill and
thank God I'm a dentist is what
marchibroda is different though because
if he was part of the part of the
offense that the Kay gun that you ran
and you ran so expertly with Widmark
levy but he your phone did ring from
from the Ravens oh yeah I even took a
visit I didn't with her and talked to
them and we're not ready to negotiate
and that's when I decide you know what I
don't need to do this I need to stay
away from the game I played enough I
want to be a Buffalo Bill forever and
more importantly I had to focus on my
son you know and it's so neat that
you're here because you know you come
almost every year when we're here at the
Hall of Fame
always been great and seems every year
we're talking about either a new coach
or a new beginning but a new quarterback
and you're like I kind of you know I'm
buying in I figure this out are you are
you still buying in with his log on
there number one yes I it's almost like
I have to I live on yeah I know what
you're planning a wedding there well
also I bought in to Rex's talk just like
most people did I like Rex
Craig I think he's maybe too nice of a
guy let players be themselves too much I
don't know all the ins and outs of what
went wrong but discipline was one I
think was a major factor number two is I
think a lot of injuries don't help don't
help a new coach either when you get
your star players or any training room
getting treatment for their injuries but
on Ron Rivera I saw it as past Super
Bowl and he told me so Jim I think you
guys got to keep in coach Shawn
McDermott he said I'm not just saying it
the same said I knew sooner or later he
was going to be picked up by somebody
and because I really think he's a guide
that's going to turn the Buffalo goes
around and then we had of course we had
a big dinner with me Bruce ermine Andre
Darrell Cornelius
Steve Tasker he wouldn't have dinner
with all his praise on what what did it
take to get to how we did it even though
we didn't win any but how'd you guys
keep coming back and of course to make a
long story short is everybody held
themselves accountable for what they did
not only when they were in a training
facility but once they'd left or what
are you going to do I did are you going
to represent the Buffalo Bills and the
mental part for us was probably more in
the physical part because I knew
everybody physically would be ready to
go but after we told after you lose
three Super Bowls all the negativity
that you'll hear in the Aussie how you
guys can't land what's everybody's
mindsets going to be and thank all we
get a coach like Marv levy who was able
to put
all this together and have us all
understand that if we're going to do
this we get to do together all these
egos got to be put to check they're all
going to come together so for me making
sure Prince McDermott knows that
everybody's going to hold themselves
accountable and understand where he came
from and who you represent you think is
the make-or-break year for Sammy Watkins
and welcome New York yeah without that
yeah again he's got to get the football
but you guys stay healthy too he said
some long Knicks in the road there's
some big potholes but he is a heck of a
player I just hope that Tyrod stays
healthy enough and gets him the football
and the contains we still have a kind
number we're number 12 on the Patriots
called Tom Brady is still in our in our
division so that doesn't help but you
know what
we'll see take care of ourselves and
we'll see what out well he's going to be
one of those guys one day who strolls in
here and calls her mr. Kelly you know
what he does now in the doctor I mean
well he just turned 40 yes right now he
just turned 40 we're used to where were
you when you were 40 you're at ESPN
doing disorder again it's not nice but
when I retired I went to NBC and then of
course NBC's lost to CBS CBS took over
and then I was with NFL countdown for a
couple years but probably one of the
worst times of my life was after I
retire because my son was born in two
weeks after I retired on my birthday and
all the things he went through on things
our family's going through during that
time but you know what I'm here now sure
and hopefully making a different course
in just a couple more minutes with Jim
Kelly we'll send you into that luncheon
Brady thinks you could play five more
years would you put anything five I
doubt it two two three probably more
three than two yeah I can see that you
can't take care of your buddy we're just
talking about all the stuff please take
it and eat and right and great right
ours was after practice we'd goes a big
treat Red Wings a burger and about three
or four beers got a couple shots and go
home get ready for practice and I said
hey we're going to have wings that today
that's that was our regimen
but regimen by the way I love the use of
regimen so here I mean we had to do what
we had to do and we had fun we enjoyed
ourselves routine Oh Bruce and Andre
Thurmond all them oh yes we had fun even
though we didn't win we all came
together and we still get together right
and did you consider Brady and all time
V greatest of all time
he's definitely taught through is no
darling it may be probably number one
evening the guy makes it happen with
whoever he has he's got the you know the
door to keep swinging open and somebody
else walks in and makes them good
somebody else leaves somebody else comes
in it doesn't matter who it is he always
finds a way to get it done Jim go into
that luncheon man have a great time with
it and love you love great seeing you
not viewing you not my face I love great
seeing you and I'll see you tonight at
the jacket dinner and then at the Jones
bash I appreciate it and it's always
good to talk to you buddy and you will
see done really got a real short road
here some positive you gotta that's Jim
Kelly the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches